hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve min stack so this is a
pretty good design problem and the
description is pretty simple so our job
is to design a stack class that supports
four operations obviously we want to
push on to the stack we want to be able
to pop from the stack and we want to be
able to get the top value on the stack
and last but not least the fourth one
this is the part that's going to be
tricky we want to be able to retrieve
the minimum element in constant time so
we want to be able to do all four of
these operations in constant time now if
you are familiar with a stack data
structure you know that by default a
stack will be able to support adding a
value popping a value and getting the
top value all three of those in of one
time now i'm not going to go into the
details of how to actually implement a
stack you can implement it with a linked
list or you can do it with an array in
this problem we're basically just going
to use the built-in data structure that
is pretty much implemented as a stack
but the main part of this problem is
being able to do this last operation
getting the minimum value from the stack
in o of one time
right because by default a stack doesn't
support this operation
now a stack let's say we're implementing
it with an array so let's say this is
our stack and let's say we do a few
operations let's just look at this
example right we push a negative
negative two we push it let's say to the
bottom of the stack we push another
value a zero we push another value
negative three and now so we did three
push operations now we wanna do a get
min so how exactly are we gonna be able
to get the minimum here well a naive way
would be just look at every single value
negative three zero negative two so we
can look through the entire the entire
stack that's gonna be o of n time to get
the minimum so at least we have a
baseline at least we know how to do it
in o of n time that's not too bad but
how can we do better how can we actually
get it to be o of one and if you want to
try to figure it out yourself i
recommend taking a look at this hint
that leak code actually provides they
say consider each value in the stack
having a corresponding minimum value
think about that for a second so let's
go back to the basics when we were
adding three values so when we first
added a value we added a negative two so
what's the minimum at this point in our
stack when we only had one value the
minimum at that point was negative two
right when we added another value we
added a zero what was the minimum at
this point when we added the zero
did this replace our current minimum
negative two no it did not so in other
words we can leave our minimum as it is
but that's not always going to work
having a single value maintaining the
minimum isn't always going to work
because for example let's say we added
another negative 2. okay our minimum
stays the exact same negative 2 right
now what if we pop this negative 2 okay
we pop that negative two now how do we
know what's the new minimum is the
minimum gonna stay negative two or is it
gonna be zero well of course we know
it's gonna be stay it's gonna stay as
negative two but how can we do that so a
good workaround is let's for each
position
write down what's the minimum at this
point so when we pop then we know okay
this is going to be the new minimum so
let's say at this point the minimum
stays negative two and we added a third
value remember we added a negative three
so now what's the new minimum we can we
can compute it in o of one time by just
comparing this new value we added and
comparing the current minimum obviously
negative three is smaller so at this
point in our stack the minimum value is
negative three if we were to pop this
negative three then the new minimum
would be a negative two right this would
be the top of our stack this would be
the minimum so far so what you might be
noticing is on this right hand side i'm
actually defining another stack right we
have two stacks one stack is telling us
the values that we've added so far in
the order that we added them the other
the other stack is telling us what's the
minimum value that we have added so far
in each position of the stack so if we
add a value we'll be inserting into both
stacks if we pop a value we'll be
popping from both stacks when we get the
top value of our stack right because
remember that's an operation the top
value we're going to be looking at the
first stack we're just going to say okay
this is the most recently added value in
the stack when we do the get min
operation we're going to look at the top
of our minimum stack get that in o of
one time right we just have to get one
value so we can do an o of one time
don't have to pop anything we just have
to take a look at our second stack so
that is the main idea it's a little
tricky to actually come up with this but
once you do it's very simple so now
let's actually jump into the code okay
so now let's get into the coding portion
so we know that we have to support four
operations and in our constructor the
first thing we're going to do is since
we know we're going to have two stacks
let's define those stacks first of all
and like i said i'm going to be
implementing this with an array or at
least an array list if you were using
java this is not just an ordinary array
we can append pop from it it's basically
python's implementation of a like a
regular stack we're going to have a
second array which is going to be the
min stack and initially they're going to
be empty so the simple thing to do is
push right that's the first operation so
on our first stack it's always going to
be easy right we're always going to take
the input value and append it to the
first stack now with the second stack we
need to know for the second stack if
there's already a value inserted in the
minimum stack then we're going to take
the minimum of the input value and the
minimum value or at least the value at
the top of our min stack and take the
minimum of those two and then append
that value to the min stack so let's
update our value first of all let's set
it equal to the minimum of itself and
the minimum of the top of our min stack
so let's say self.min stack at negative
one at least that's how you do it in
python but we know that this min stack
actually could be
non-empty so we're gonna only do this if
our self.min stack is non-empty
otherwise let's just take the minimum of
val and val so i this might be a little
complicated i probably could have just
done an if else statement but in python
i feel like this is a little bit cleaner
so we're just taking the minimum of
value and the top of our stack if the
stack is not empty if it is empty we're
just taking the minimum of val and val
because if the stack is empty then of
course we're just going to take the
men's stack and append
the value to it right so when we append
this value it should be the minimum of
the input value and the minimum of the
top of the min stack so that's all for
our push function now let's do the pop
function we don't have to return
anything all we have to do is pop from
our stack but since we have two stacks
we're gonna have to pop from both of
these stacks so popping from the first
stack and popping from the minimum stack
so that definitely takes care of
everything for us
it feels like cheating since we're
pretty much using the built-in functions
and to get the top value of the stack we
are going to take from the top of the
first stack right we by top we want to
get the last value that was inserted and
this is always going to be called when
our stack is non-empty so we don't have
to take care of any edge cases the last
one get min is going to be returning
from the top of the min stack right
because we want the minimum value that's
always going to be on the top of the min
stack and this function as well is only
going to be called when our stack is
non-empty so that is the entire code and
of course for some reason i didn't
notice that i didn't actually put the
else over here so if it was confusing
before i'm really sorry about that so
now you can probably tell exactly what's
going on because it's pretty simple so
this is what we're going to be
evaluating if our stack is not empty
else this expression is going to
evaluate just to this value and then
we'll of course take the minimum of
these two
so now this code is complete you can see
that it's very efficient because every
single one of these four functions is
done in o of one time so i hope that
this was helpful if it was please like
and subscribe it supports the channel a
lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching